à quoi sert le 20 octobre qu'elle
était bien d'abord et avant tout à
produire des lois des règlements et
directives
ce pouvoir législatif à l'aide de
trois institutions c'est ce qu'on
appelle le triangle institutionnel il
yad'abord la commission qui représente
l'intérêt général de l'union puis le
conseil des ministres qui représente
les gouvernements et enfin le parlement
qui représente les citoyens puisque
c'est la seule institution et les
procès fragile recel direct
si on veut faire une simple comparaison
le parlement européen ne serait
assimilable au bout de stagner
ou à l'assemblée nationale en france
et le conseil de l'union européenne
serait-elle si minable e
au bout d'un certain temps à un mano
évidemment au sénat
en france donc il ya l'idée que il faut
dans le système communautaire associé
d'un côté
les citoyens et de l'autre les zetas
avouez que le traité de maastricht dans
les 292 heures le parlement et le
constat que partage le pouvoir
législatif
cette procédure s'appelle la
codécision mais milan ni l'autre ne
peuvent proposer de loi
ce triangle et puis un triangle
largement il égalitaire
puisque le parlement la partie
l'initiative législatives il n'a pas
par exemple ce que l'assemblée pour le
sénat en france compte
la proposition de loi ils ne peuvent pas
proposer de loi
la commission qu'il y a elle seule ce
monopole de l'initiative est donc c une
autre particularité de ce système
politique européen qui explique en
partie la nécessité de ce triangle
après la navette entre le parlement et
le conseil la proposition de loi
règlements directives patatra adoptée
mais en cas de désaccord
un comité de conciliation se réunit
l'équivalent en france de la commission
mixte paritaire et les composés de 54
membres moitié parlement moitié
conseil hilare six semaines pour trouver
un accord soit la proposition beta band
au nez soit elle est adoptée
alors à l'issue de ce processus une
particularité du système communautaire
alain on rentre peut-être dans la
complexité de la législation
communautaire c'est
ils ont aussi hâte de grands sacs tête
il ya un acte d'effet direct ce qu'on
appelle le règlement qui n'a pas besoin
au pied des faits comme son nom l
indique direct dans toutes les
législations
et parce qu'elle était la plus connue
donc tout on a parlé évidemment au
moment de la fameuse directive
bolkenstein à une directive services c
l adjectif donc il faut bien comprendre
qu'une directive
comme son nom l'indiqué c'est un sens
à donner à la législation
mais cette législation pour être mises
en oeuvre
effective pour être d'application dans
les états membres doit être
transposée une directive doit être
transposée c'est-à-dire inséré dans
le droit interne de chaque état dans un
délai de trois ans
mais certains dépassent largement les
délaisse a longtemps été le cas de la
france qui était le plus mauvais
élève de l'europe la france a fait des
progrès et aujourd'hui elle se situe
plutôt dans le peloton de tête des 27
états membres